what's going on guys this is rob and
word has reached my ears that they are
apparently changing the origin of name
of the submariner for the marvel
cinematic universe
and it actually makes good sense that
they're doing that because if they kept
namor's origin the same well there is
the obvious allusions to uh to aquaban
of atlantis which i really think is the
least of their concerns i mean honestly
i feel like if even if neymar was just a
carbon copy of aquaman in terms of
origin people would still say the movies
better which it would be but
the other reason why i think this is a
good idea is because of the nature of
atlantis trying to cram all that history
in to what would basically be a 15
minute or so segment of the film
would be insane and it would just be too
much to try to do so according to these
leaks that are coming out because again
it's not really confirmed by marvel but
according to the leaks that are coming
out what they're saying is the character
will not originate in atlantis as in the
comics but in the central american
region and will come from a historic and
submerged city of mexican culture in
addition he will be the son of a human
with a queen of the submerged people and
that tanakh huerta will play the
character who will also be accompanied
by a royal guard so i i hope i
pronounced that first name correctly i'm
terrible when it comes to to latin
american pronunciations for names but um
i think this is a smart idea and and
here's the thing right having them come
from like any other region is fine
because it just it works it's simple
it's really really quick it's easy to
understand the fact that as people have
been submerged and just kind of hidden
away from society for quite some time
people will be like the average person
will be able to pick up on the fact that
it's basically atlantis what this does
is it gives marvel the ability to dodge
answering the question how long has
atlanta's been here and what's its
history right so here's the thing let's
let's let me give you guys the rundown
on atlantis and then you guys tell me in
the comments if you think it's practical
to explain this
even just a semblance of this history in
the span of 15 minutes which is all we
would really have in that film since
we're focusing on namor and like the
events of wakanda and so on and so forth
so the way this works and in order to
grasp atlantis there's a few things you
have to know and the first of these is
that there are differing accounts as to
the history of atlantis itself you've
got the submariner number ten from
volume one you've got invaders volume
three issue number twelve you've got
avengers annual number 20 which i
actually didn't know about i'd never
read that comic my editor pointed it out
to me and i was like this is a really
important thing so kudos to alex for
finding that but there are differing
accounts about its history but there is
a kind of generality insofar as how
things just generally transpired as an
overall concept in marvel comics
relating to atlantis the atlanteans how
they came into existence and all that
kind of stuff again and like uh invaders
uh volume three issue number 12 for
example the idea is that the atlanteans
actually come from a planet called vodan
so they're not native to earth they
actually just came here somewhere along
the line and they've been here and we
don't know anything other than that
that's literally it they're just they're
from vodan and like that's all marvel
gave us
so again their their own history is a
little questionable but going with the
generally accepted history of atlantis
if you look at the world as it exists
today it's not that dissimilar from the
way the world existed at the time of the
atlanteans i mean you're talking about
or at least the time
of of this era in comics right you're
talking about a 30 000 year period and
as you guys know land masses don't shift
drastically over the course of 30 000
years so what you ended up having of
course was pangaea the giant land mass
that existed it broke apart and when
that happened you basically had four
giant chunks of land the first one was
the americas so what we in this day and
age would consider everything
west of the atlantic ocean right so
north america south america all that
stuff beyond that or in the atlantic
ocean you had atlantis and lemuria and
then to the east of that you have
everything that we would consider in the
modern era to be asia europe all that
stuff right so those are like the four
giant land masses as they were named
at that point in time now as you guys
may know just from either reading about
it or or looking up articles or having
seen my videos or other people's videos
somewhere along the line about you know
30 some odd thousand years ago or so the
celestials showed up on earth and
modified the genes of early man in the
form of the wonderers this took place in
the atlantic and lumerian territories
but the important thing is that these
individuals their genes were modified so
that one third would become eternals one
third would become deviants and one
third would have their genes modified so
that at some future point in time they
would develop powers marvel uses that as
an explanation for one the origin of
mutants why it is that people started
just getting these x genes activating
all over the place and two how it is
that someone like steve rogers could be
exposed to the super soldier program and
not die of radiation sickness and
instead become captain america it's kind
of marvel's way of booking those
explanations in for how that stuff
happens but the long and short of this
and really for our discussion we're
focusing on lumeria and we're focusing
or at least lemuria and we're focusing
on atlantis so the idea behind this is
that you had basically the deviants that
set up residence in lemuria and ruled it
with an iron fist in effect the eternals
had basically abandoned their role of
keeping humanity safe or protecting
humanity from the inherent violent
nature of the deviants the eternals just
didn't really care now there were some
who did
gilgamesh and like icarus and those guys
they stood up for humanity and they
basically found themselves involved in
wars against the deviants to protect
humanity but aside from them most
eternals didn't care and rightfully so
they were dealing with their own civil
war but the thing about this is that the
deviants captured or conquered
most of the world and in fact the only
territory that was governed by humans
that was safe from the control of the
deviants was atlantis and there were a
couple different reasons for this one
because atlantis was so technologically
advanced they were capable of being able
to repel the forces of lemuria but the
second reason for this is because
atlantis was a huge trading hub because
it was a free territory that was not
conquered by the by the deviants it
basically meant that you had a huge
cultural exchange here so you could you
could go to atlantis and get things that
you wouldn't otherwise be able to get in
different parts of the world this was
also the reason why while the deviants
did try to capture atlantis a few times
they were really more half-hearted
measures right it was kind of an
exercise in displaying their power as
opposed to a genuine desire to capture
atlantis different you know rulers of
the of the deviants did actually want to
conquer it legitimately but for the most
part they never really succeeded however
atlantis itself was governed by a a kind
of religious society or a religious uh
monarchy if you want to call it that the
reason why this matters is because with
these different priests and priestesses
that were practicing magic what they
realized is that with the deviants
consistently trying to conquer the
atlanteans a time would come when only
one of two things would happen either
the deviants would be successful in
which case all would be lost or there
would be some kind of massive situation
where both atlantis and the deviant
empire of lemuria would be destroyed in
the process some great big huge
cataclysm war or something along those
lines in order to protect themselves
from that the royal family if you want
to call it that or the inner circle or
the ruling body or what have you
constructed domes in atlantis itself
that were effectively impenetrable that
were indestructible and so what this
meant is that even if the deviants
managed to successfully launch an attack
in atlantis they never would have been
able to destroy the governing body this
was particularly important because
around this time you basically ended up
having the celestials that returned to
earth in their second host to
essentially look over their experiment
and see how it was progressing when they
realized that the eternals had abandoned
their role in safeguarding humanity and
allowed the deviants to just kind of do
their own thing the eternals of course
were drastically punished by the by the
celestials but the deviants had actually
attacked the celestials and so what it
did is it led to the celestials
attacking the deviants and obliterating
the capital city of lemuria when this
happened you basically saw the quote
unquote sinking of lemuria and atlantis
because they were in effect the same
giant land mass the results of this is
that lemuria sank atlantis fell before
the oceans but because of the of the
domes that were constructed by the
atlanteans themselves it kept them
protected from
basically drowning and so what this did
is it essentially led to uh the the
various priests and so on modifying the
genealogy of those humans in atlantis to
give them the ability to breathe
underwater and that's why they went
forward as the atlanteans now when it
came to lemuria you actually saw south
lemuria i think which was essentially uh
well the deviants that just kind of
reconstructed their empire there as kind
of an underground layer uh but north
lemuria was actually explored by the
atlanteans as a branch off group and
they formed a society for themselves
over there so that's why if you ever
read moral comics or you look up a
marvel wiki or something like that
you'll see lemuria referred to twice one
as a territory belonging to the deviants
and two as the same territory being
ruled by the atlanteans because
technically speaking a branch broke off
and then went to lemuria itself now
beyond that there's other huge things
that you could tie in this is why
offering an explanation like this in the
movie while it's way too long for a
15-minute segment it could actually do
wonders for building up the mythos of
the mcu because we know that you have
like sir percy of scandia you know we
know you have like black knight right
dane whitman uh the the ebony blade and
all that kind of stuff here's a crazy
thing that you may not know among all
the different people who were powerful
in the realm of magic and so on and so
forth that resided in atlantis you had
two individuals that were more important
than the others the first one was a
woman named morgan lefay who basically
is this woman that's ridiculously
powerful in terms of sorcery and all
that kind of stuff in terms of magic and
is actually on par with doctor doom and
then you had another guy named meredin
now that name may sound familiar to you
and the reason why is because meridian
had at one point left atlantis taking up
residence in england as part of king
arthur's knights of the round table and
changed his name to merlin now
eventually he he left that you know when
they all went to other world and
everything he bailed out on that and
then he formed the omniversal
development court he just sits on high
just monitoring and judging the
multiverse right just as you would
expect with a guy who's probably a dick
but like there's a lot of things that
you could tie in right i mean you could
literally say like merlin and all that
stuff is real like it's all actual
things and you can actually use dane
whitman as a link to that right and then
bring like atlantis in and tie and
really introduce this idea that all this
history is tied together but again
that's a lot to explain that's a lot to
dump in a 15 minute segment way too much
for us to see in in black panther too
now if we ever got a name or the
submariner movie or if they gave us a tv
show that explored the history of
atlantis that would be great because
i've long since said really one of the
best untapped possibilities in the
marvel cinematic universe right now is
for them to basically do what i did with
marvel comics which was a history of the
marvel universe where we basically broke
down the entire history of all the the
origins and everything in marvel comics
right like the origins of the cree the
scrolls the the nova corps earth mutants
all that kind of stuff like we broke all
that stuff down into this great big huge
series and i feel like that is an
amazing untapped possibility for the mcu
to basically create what is in effect a
documentary or a mockumentary series on
disney plus that gives us this whole
history of earth in the marvel cinematic
universe and even the alternate
realities i'm sorry the the alternate
planets and places across the universe i
think the reason they haven't done that
is because ever since the end of
infinity war and avengers in-game
they've kind of been flying by the seat
of their pants it feels like it
which is why i think this 10-year thing
with kevin feige is particularly
important right they're going out and
planning this 10-year period in the mcu
like what comes next for the next 10
years i think it's a really really big
deal but nonetheless right let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
do you think this is too much for us to
explain over the course of namor the
submariner's appearance in black panther
ii do you think they should have like
their own series right like a
mockumentary series or a tv series that
explores all this let me know what you
guys think but thank you all for
watching and i'll catch you all later
peace